[Music]
i'm afraid that if i leave here like i'm
just not it's not going to be the same
feeling like over video chat and all
that you know and he does make me happy
when we're not fighting
okay bye-bye bye thank you
is there going to be
a goodbye kiss on the lips
i'm so
i am no no yes no
kissing you in the airport is just like
a public announcement so many things i
do
for you not because i want to because i
want to make you happy
can we just go
you need to be in the center to meet
your balance anything that didn't favor
you no it's fine you show anger i'm not
i'm just saying that like my plane's
gonna leave soon
so
this has been an experience of a
lifetime
and i'm leaving as usman's girlfriend i
should be going home happy
but the fact that he won't kiss me in
public still
still after all this time
it hurts me a little bit it's like you
know are you ashamed of me i mean what
is it
[Music]
you're so dumb
all right i'll see you later yeah
love you bye-bye bye
i don't know where things are going to
go in the future with usman and i
it's really hard to be in a
long-distance relationship
you have to be so secure
and sometimes he makes me feel insecure
[Music]
and now i'm leaving on a doubtful note
like how are we gonna make this work
i'm taking another chance by trusting
him to not break my heart when i get
back to the states
but i think gusman is worth the risk
[Music]
you